fight we've got about half an hour to
talk about the third and most if you
like immediate elements of the crisis in
capitalism which is the crisis of the
single currency area the eurozone Gideon
is this a crisis of what a root is the
cause of this crisis is it policymakers
and their stupidity at jumping into
something which doesn't work and never
would have worked the private sector for
lending money willy-nilly without
realizing the grease isn't in fact
Germany or something else well I fear
that the that crisis is actually to do
with the single currency and so that
having created a common currency without
a common government that's that's the
the root of the dilemma and that they
therefore this kind of pressure on
Germany to build a bigger fire wall just
to breathe the euro bonds etc although
there's an enormous amount of it I do
feel a bit I unfashionably perhaps
sympathetic towards the Germans I was
just didn't Berlin and you know they
were there they're just been got a
frightful bashing at Davos everyone from
David Cameron to Tim Geithner and had
lined up to say you know the Germans
essentially have just got to write a
bigger check and you talk to the Germans
they've actually already put down 211
billion euros worth of guarantees for
the various firewall funds and that are
being asked to write even more that's
that's equivalent to eighty percent of
their national budget and I think
they're understandably reluctant to do
it and similarly on the argument of euro
bonds essentially they're being asked to
underwrite the debts of southern Europe
without any control of the spending of
southern Europe and when there was a
suggestion that perhaps that should be
put into place there were effectively
call Nazis for
so for asking for what seemed to me
perfectly reasonable suggestive so the
trunk that the trouble is that if you
have eurobonds and physical control
essentially you're talking about a
European policy and I don't think we're
anywhere near being able to get to that
and then you know you talk to a lot of
economists and certainly American
economist you don't really have a view
of European politics and they will say
well obviously you're just going to have
to end up with the political union and
that's how this story has to end because
otherwise it's not going to work but I
just don't from what I know of European
politics i just don't think we'll get
there so we're in a rather hideous
dilemma and I think although the Germans
are still you know who you know if they
have any culpability it's essentially
because they came up with this idea of
the Euro that kind of a kind of stuck
with it now and and I think there's a
sort of horrible sick feeling dawning on
a lot of the people trying to sort
things out and Berlin that this is the
problem and a German friend of mine who
works quite high up in the Foreign
Ministry's said there's rather strange
lovely and moment he said we have
invented a machine from hell that we
cannot turn off and I thought that was a
fairly good summary of the situation it
Stephen do you share that really
slightly grim prognosis that they either
have to do something that is a huge step
onto political union they're probably
not ready for or face horrible crisis in
unraveling this egg that they've already
scrambled what's your take and I think I
agree in the sense that we can't stay
where we are currently so there are two
extreme choices one is the particular
Union choice and the other is that the
whole thing breaks up a little debate
about what will happen if the whole
thing were to break up but I think that
what you would find is that you have a
massive collapse of cross-border capital
flows across the eurozone you have huge
problems with solvency liquidity and you
want to find one potential trigger for
the next Great Depression it would be
the collapse of the euro so whatever
happens it all looks incredibly
difficult however I'm not going to be
quite so sympathetic towards the Germans
I think that they suffer from a degree
of economic illiteracy when it comes to
this debate and if you talk to people in
Germany and say what are the secrets of
your economic success they'll say it's
hard work being competitive it's showing
the inflation is low and ideally also
running a large current account surplus
and there was a trade surplus and then
you say well do you think all other
countries should follow the German
example let's say absolutely you begin
to realize it unless we start doing
trade with Jupiter on Mars look
difficult to make the numbers add up I
think also that in the period prior to
the crisis not just the eurozone crisis
but the overall financial crisis it's
important to remember that the
imbalances in the eurozone were not the
consequence of those who are owed too
much and thinking here the southern
European nations but instead it was a
consequence of those who lent too much
those in Northern Europe and that
includes German financial institutions
Germans savers indirectly and the reason
why I say that is that in the years
in the run-up to the financial crisis
the cost of borrowing for Greece
Portugal Italy Spain Ireland collapsed
it became easier and easier for them to
borrow because the lenders became ever
more generous and and the lenders always
assume they'll get their money back and
that was a very rare rash assumption so
what we've ended up with is this huge
imbalance the creditors want their money
back but the ability of the debtors to
repay has fallen not because they
borrowed too much in one sense in the
first mission rather because the
financial crisis has left levels of
income everywhere in the eurozone much
lower than was the case previously now
for me that something will have to
change over the course of the next few
months it could become quite nasty even
if there's an optimistic story at the
very end of this and that is that if
creditors insist that des has had to do
all the adjusting eventually the dangers
the debtors will simply collapse and
when they collapse the creditors will
also be in trouble now if you go back to
the 1930s there was a kind of almost a
dress rehearsal for these kinds of
issues today the dress rehearsal
involved France which was the equivalent
of Germany today being a major creditor
nation and it involved Austria which was
really the equivalent of the southern
European nations today Austria was under
the gold standard facing terrible
difficulties had to deliver continuous
austerity of the kind of we see in
southern Europe today in the process of
delivering austerity it had a series of
corporate failures that was threatened
with a series of bank failures and the
Austrians asked others for some help the
French gave them some help and the
Austrians for reasons best known to
themselves decided to enter into a
customs union with Germany this was 1931
not the best year of the Austrians and
Germans plans to get together into a
customs union but the consequence of
this and was that the French so we're
going to do this we're going to withhold
the next tranche of the loan because the
French believe that as creditors they
could dictate
the debtors how they should behave the
consequences of that withholding that
particular loan was a failure of credit
and stout one of the major Austrian
banks and the failure of credit and
shelter today is routinely regarded by
economic historians as one of the key
triggers that took us from a great
recession to a great depression and the
irony of the story in the years that
followed was the country that really
suffered in Europe in the Great
Depression wasn't so much Austria it was
France because as a creditor it suddenly
discovered that the debtors it lent to
couldn't repair and I think is the
problem for Jeremy today that although
it's absolutely true what Gideon says
about this whole issue about how much
the Germans have to power up in terms of
fiscal policy and so on and so forth
whatever happens there go have to pay a
very large bill the question is whether
the bill is paid on an orderly basis or
whether it's paid on a very very
disorderly basis interesting very stinky
busy let's get a quick comment from
Anatole Linda and then we'll go to the
floor well I agree with all of that I
think those were two brilliant analyses
I think I think Stephens story can
really be summed up about in single
sentence which is that a financial
crisis is not when money is lost it's
when people realize that money has been
lost and that's basically what you know
that the Germans have lost a hell of a
lot of money over the last 10 years for
exactly the reason that Stephen gave
they were they were falling over
themselves to lend to agree to the Greek
government to buy condominiums on the
Costa Brava and so on so forth all these
things are worthless and basically the
Germans are the ones who have to add you
know that who have to pay up they made
the foolish investment they're in
exactly the same position visa V the
rest of Europe as the greedy rich
bankers are visa V the mortgage holders
in the US and I think they've got to
recognize that the only gloss that I
would put on it as I I think perhaps
contrary to Gideon I think there's
actually a fair chance that Europe will
turn into a single state over the
next five years or so i think that is
there any solution if it doesn't do that
it's got a breakup so one way or the
other we're at a tremendously historical
moment but i think the willingness for
among the countries or the people even
of much of the eurozone to accept some
kind of federal government similar to
the united states is probably much
greater than people in britain or indeed
in America recognized partly because the
traditions of national sovereignty the
political sovereignty as opposed to
cultural sovereignty are not that strong
in mostly your own southern European
countries Italy Greece Spain have not
been independent countries for a lot of
the of the last hundred a couple of
hundred years so I think the real
problem is that there are two countries
in which the traditions of national
sovereignty a very strong and they are
Germany in France and the question is
which of them is actually going to run a
united Europe and I think yer if the
whole system collapses it will be over
that rivalry between France and Germany
it's got nothing to do with Greece Italy
or Spain whatever whatever happens in
five years time the problem is very very
bad right now we have and that is the
unemployment particularly of young
people particularly in those countries
in southern Europe it can you imagine
finishing university or school and not
being able to get a job anywhere four
years ago the unemployment rate in
Germany and Spain was the same today the
unemployment rate in Germany is not much
more than five percent and in Spain it's
thirty percent and that's the result of
the fact that money can't be transferred
from the rich countries to the poor
countries in any single nation state the
tax is paid by the rich areas like
London and between forty and fifty
percent of that is distributed by the
government to the
poorer regions and that's how a
political nation state works we don't
have that in Europe and if we have to
wait five years there'll be five years
of massive numbers of young people
unemployed and that's something we can't
I think accept and therefore I think we
should it's not up to us but I think the
17 countries in the euro should go back
to our national currencies and allow
themselves to become competitive again
so they can start earning their way for
giving their debts and paying the money
doesn't help they've got to become
competitive and they can only do that by
having currencies which they can devalue
once they become
very briefly junk you can have it both
Clara too wild unrealistic assumptions
in all of this which are very widespread
the first is that the answer is
political union the second is that if
only the Germans would get on with it
and issue euro Olivia see of eurobonds
and basically pay for it the problems
would be solved suppose imagine for a
moment we had political union imagine
for a moment that Chancellor Merkel is
not Chancellor of Germany but Chancellor
of Europe what exactly is she going to
be able to do as Chancellor of Europe to
deal with the problems of people rioting
in the streets of Athens with a general
strike in southern in parts of southern
Europe virta mr. papit Amos is not able
to do in his office in athens today she
can pay their wages right the only thing
she can do is refuse to pay their wages
pay their way right all right before
right before or right or she can pay
their wages right which is pretty good
news not just in Greece it's good news
in Portugal in Spain in Italy in every
other country of the European Union as
well this is just not going to happen
even if people describe something as
political union that reality is not
going to emerge from it the second
closely related policy which is the one
and at all picked up straight away is
the one that says everyone knows what
the answer is it is that Germany pays
it's like our saying none of us are sure
our what we're doing for dinner tonight
but we can all agree what to do evan
Davis will pay for it
we can all vote for that there's just
one problem and it's an insoluble
problem and intractable problem and
that's the problem we have here I'm
sorry but the problems we have in the
eurozone today do not seem to me admit
to admit of easy solution or probably
any solution and the notion that there
are answers to be God if only we would
struggle towards them is just a mistake
and I'm ascensor quick comment from
Linda and then we'll have a couple of
questions and just thinking a little bit
about and I you know there are a lot of
difficulties for countries currently in
the eurozone and they're the reason why
you hear a lot of these terms being
thrown around transfers political union
is because ultimately a monetary union
can only survive if it's what economists
call optimal currency union so that just
is very simple they don't you criteria
one is you share currency with countries
you trade a lot with because you think
that should benefit to that that you're
to give up your own currency for making
trade easier crossing borders cheaper
but there's a second criteria and this
is where I think countries really have
to look hard at whether or not they
actually meet which is convergence
convergence and incomes convergence and
business cycles will all do all these
countries can they really converge to
the likes of Germany or the Netherlands
and just if they can't then I think the
issue is is it really in their benefit
to stay in the eurozone and I think
that's the question which is confronting
a lot of the peripheral countries right
now because we'll just take Greece is a
quick example although this could be
very long so I we're just going to make
it quick which is that they do
everything which is now asked of them by
the European Union the IMF the ECB and
they will still end up in by 2020 with a
debt to gdp ratio of a hundred and
twenty percent so that's austerity for
another nine years and with rising
unemployment rising of homelessness the
question I think it needs to ask itself
is should I stay in this currency union
if ultimately I don't fit the criteria
of an OCA I think that's the question
that all these countries will have to
struggle with and of course the
consequences as we've all mentioned are
messy by twenty twenty years by 2020 it
ends up where Italy is now basically our
visit the good news for 45 degrees let's
take a couple of a couple of questions
we'll take one up there but first we'll
take one over here yeah um one of these
things that under the panelists talked
about was what you think the policy of
the government in this country should be
towards coming up with the solution okay
that's a good question i'm going to let
diane take that first and meanwhile
we'll get ready for a question up there
go ahead down well i think in this
situation it's hard for the british
government to offer advice to the
members of the eurozone and be taken
very seriously but we have to recognize
that our fortunes very closely tied to
those of the eurozone it's our major
trading partner our financial
institutions very closely tied with all
these are these trades that we were
discussing earlier and so we can't
afford to be complacent about it at all
but I've been listening to this bit of
this at the discussion and it strikes me
that nobody has mentioned the biggest
euro crisis of all which is that these
are countries whose demography is such
that their aging very rapidly their
populations will start shrinking they're
not innovating and there's no growth so
these are countries of old people run by
old people for old people and it's no
wonder they've got twenty-five percent
thirty percent youth unemployment and
given our own situation again it's quite
hard for us to to offer advice about how
to grow the economy and tackle youth
unemployment we're all in that vote
together but those are the areas where I
think all the government should be
focusing their attention Gideon baidu
over you
to join us the Europeans to join the UK
stole emoji the Irish Mike but no i mean
i think that the position of the British
government particular British Tory
government is very interesting on this
because of course they were your as
skeptics they didn't believe in the
single currency and half of them wants
to say this single currency was a huge
mistake and it should obviously break up
but every study they've had done for
them by the Treasury tells them don't do
it it'll be a total disaster and so
people like cameron and osborne rather
against their natural instinct so say
urging the Europeans to go for political
union because that's their toll is the
only way to avoid the implosion of the
European financial system but
unfortunately as I said and they're
going to get that either following on
from the question about the Austrian
economists who predicted the financial
crisis perhaps they hope to a point bill
cash our president in Europe alone elida
other people who predicted the euro
crisis and orderly orderly winding down
of it yeah we'll take a quick guy one up
there and then where was the next one I
think we had someone over there yeah and
Diane somewhat preempted my question
because what I wanted to ask the panel
is we have heard nothing from any of you
about where you think growth is going to
come from both for the UK and also
within Europe and I'd be interested to
hear your views 0 where it might come
from thank you for that question I'm
going to park that because of the in a
couple of minutes to finish I want to
just whip down the whole line and ask
you whether you think we will be richer
per capita in 10 years time than we are
now or not so that'll be your sort of
final question so where would it come
from if we're going to be richer or are
we not going to be richer in which case
the answer is it's not going to come
from anyway where was the next one did I
say the next one over here ya go thank
you the last the latest eurostat
employment reports showed rather
unsurprisingly a very large increase in
migration from southern Europe to
Northern Europe particular youth
migration isn't that ultimately how the
single currency construct a political
union by getting populations to move by
understanding each other's culture
by intermarrying etc it's a very
interesting point I'm going to take
another question straight away we'll
take one over here and we'll let the
panel pick up one or two at the same
time yes go ahead yes we've had
allusions to morality during the course
in this discussion I just wonder should
economic systems be run as if immoral
function existed and if so how should it
be exercised discuss okay okay we've got
two we've got migration morality let's
take one quick one and then I'm going to
let's go up back up back up to the top
floor hi I'm Nico McDonald I want to
pick up and look where will growth come
from question sir like most economic
discussions around the crisis we seem to
have focused on the financial side of it
john katie is credit pointing out that
circulating money between banks doesn't
create value and Sir Martin pointing out
that we need to be more competitive it
seems to be the root of the crisis is
probably actually in a failure in the
productive sector which Evan your book
was about I see the deal was I was going
to mention to your credit and I do
wonder when we have an economy where
even the most successful companies in
the most successful sector in ICT Apple
for instance can't actually invest the
billions of dollars it's made in profits
in any new industries markets so I think
the challenges we've got to answer is
around greater productivity and
innovation and actually creating new
industries so I think if growers are
going to come from anywhere we need to
be focusing in those domains you know I
think a lot of answers there that's a
very good very big and good question and
actually I think we should wind up the
Euro discussion now because I'd like us
to finish on time so what I just like to
say so just one thing about migration if
you look at what happened to Italy
innate 1870 they had a forced imposition
of the lira over the whole country
previous to that they'd had many
different currencies southern Italy was
poorer than law the north
we had one currency impose just like the
euro and all the people who are
energetic and able and young moved to
Brazil Argentina northern Italy and the
result was permanent impoverishment of
southern Europe which exists today and I
think that's something we should note
and not tolerate in Europe right okay
panel in a minute starting with you
Thomas will run down and we'll just ask
you each to talk about where is the
growth coming from and will we be richer
in in 10 years time I mean you basically
got 30 seconds no but just I'm going to
ask you that yet yep you're allow this
very kind of you that's you know it's
for its funny before you answer that Tom
this is you answer that before you
because I'm giving you warning so you've
got time to think about what your answer
is going to be let's just have a vote on
the euro we've had votes on the other
two sections of the discussion so the
issue has been framed as a choice
between moving further towards
integration or toward moving backwards
towards national currencies and it's not
a ridiculous way of framing the choice
the question for you is how many of you
think Europe should be putting its
efforts into advancing towards political
union to try and make the single
currency work better political union on
the one hand or how many of you would
rather they put all their efforts into
working out a way of the least
disorderly way of unraveling the thing
and moving back to something that was
less than a eurozone of 17 countries so
how many of you think they should go
along with the plan towards political
union whatever that means and how many
of you would say they should work out
how to get out of this
okay memo to Europe kensington tells you
you're better offers abandoning the
thing okay